[Music]
I wanted to first talk about there was
just a like a big like November I keep
saying that
Nantucket project event in Port Chester
right yes yeah how does it look like
amazing it was a beautiful it's in the
capital theater so typically we do our
events in the round uh-huh and this was
on a stage looking out so it's very
different the vibe was very different
and I think that we decided at the end
of the night that we really prefer to be
in the round that there's something
participatory about that that you can't
have when you're on a stage and then
also being on a stage like that can
sometimes trigger a performative element
that isn't ideal for what we're trying
to do right most people that we put on
stage that night have waited that but
there was one one part of the evening
got very like a show yeah
and we're trying super hard not to be a
show well it's hard when you scale it up
and you have that many people yeah an
attendance right yeah I mean I'll tell
you music always works so we had the
Harlem Gospel Choir uh-huh and we also
had Renee Robinson who's an Alvin Ailey
dancer and she got the audience up and
taught them this set of moves and then
the kind of big reveal was that it was
set to hello by Adele uh-huh and all of
a sudden we were dancing like like on
point everybody in the audience
everybody in the audience Wow thousand
people that's cool
awesome she she is one of those
terrifically charismatic people I mean I
would say that in the last five years
the single most charismatic person I've
ever met once
Renee Robinson I feel like I need to get
her on the podcast you do you do she's
got it whatever it is and and her she's
100% charisma for good mm-hmm
which is not always true of the the
deeply charismatic like it sometimes
turns for the worst and you find that
they're enjoying their power in ways
that are unhealthy but she's true I
don't even know if she's aware of how
charismatic are you
and Tom like find these people these
gems ah well now so this will be the
ninth year of the Nantucket project that
means that we have been in front of you
know I'm gonna say ten thousand people
maybe even more over nine years so some
percentage of those people take it upon
themselves to reach out with suggestions
and that's that's how the funnel gets
filled mm-hmm and then there's some
vetting that goes on and then you hear
about someone from three different
people and that makes you want to go
meet them and it trickles down from
there I'm in a similar situation I'm on
the receiving end of a lot of you know
suggested guess and the vetting process
for me or the litmus test really is is
it is a guttural thing like it's
instinctual like do i resonate with this
like sometimes you know multiple people
will say should have this person on but
I'm not feeling it and then I do it
anyway and that's not quite right like I
have to really it's like an unknowing
sort of thing that clicks and I'm like
oh yeah this person is right and what's
interesting about Nantucket is a lot of
these feel like a bunch of these people
are people I've never heard of you know
they're not they're not like necessarily
like people that are in mainstream
consciousness or maybe they're kind of
teetering on you know tapping into that
but it's always like it's so well
curated and I you know I have yet to see
somebody that strikes a false no well so
it's interesting it's a four-day ideas
festival on Nantucket in September and
we end up with about forty people on
stage and we have sort of this rule of
thumb that seven of them should be
household names uh-huh so that's Hope
Solo and George W Bush and Laura Dern
right and it seems like that's just
enough to give the uninitiated
confidence that it's gonna be worth
there four days right and then the real
joy of it is to find these unknown
people and in fact I was an unknown
person like that's how I came into the
Nantucket project is that I was asked to
speak because Tom had been told by a
couple different people that they had
seen
do my thing and that they really liked
it and so he came out and took me to
lunch in San Francisco at some
Vietnamese place and he said I want you
to come to Nantucket and I want you to
give the talk of your life
uh-huh and to be totally honest I was
completely offended why I thought it was
so outrageous wouldn't outrageous
assignment for somebody who I had known
for you know 40 minutes and I'd never
heard of the Nantucket project I mean
it's not it's not Ted yeah it's it's a
different thing and so anyway I but it
but it got under my skin like that idea
like it was an outrageous thing to say
to someone and also I suppose for the
right person totally irresistible uh-huh
and that became this challenge and it
really was the talk I gave was literally
the talk of my life it's the best talk I
ever gave us the hardest I ever worked
on anything it won the Audience Award
and that began our relationship and were
five years in now yeah so so how did you
go from that to becoming the creative
director I came back the following year
and interviewed a couple people I
interviewed Julie Taymor who did Lion
King on Broadway and interviewed a
wonderful young athlete who had been in
and out of jail named Maurice Clarett he
was like the number one draft pick in
the country out of Ohio State and they
ended up going to jail and he tells an
incredible story that involves Warren
Buffett and it's a great he's an amazing
guy actually be really cool for you to
talk to mighty struggles mighty
struggles and then the following year I
came back and talked to some more people
and then at some point Tom said I want
to hire you and I said well isn't your
company in Connecticut because I live in
Oakland California and by the way I
write books yeah I do have this other
job I'm like five books into this thing
and and he said it will work it out and
and and he is a person who's very
similar to you where he's operating
almost entirely on God yeah and it's
very very careful very carefully tuned
to his gut and he just can't do it if he
doesn't have it
if he doesn't have the good feeling he
just cannot do it he works in mysterious
ways like he works in mysterious ways he
does I'm Way more linear yeah
cryptic in certain respects but the
equation works and I've said this before
but like i I've known Tom and Neil
Philip since like I was 14 years old at
school with those guys and I had a kind
of checkered experience at that phase of
my life but being at at Nantucket proj
project was really healing for me to
like reconnect with them and just see
like the amazing work that both of those
guys are doing and then some of my
classmates also from that period of time
were there in attendance and I just it
was magical for me and you know I've
spoke at a lot of different events and
conferences and there was something
radically different about Nantucket that
I can't quite put my finger on it on but
I think it has something to do with just
the the heart and the integrity that you
know Tom really sets the tone with that
and the level of engagement by everybody
who attends yes and and the kind of
immersive experience that the speakers
all have like usually people fly in they
do their thing they leave but everybody
stayed the whole time they attended all
the sessions and everybody left that
experience transformed I think that my
favorite thing you're touching on like
all my favorite things about TM p1 is I
do think that it's funny and awesome
that like two six foot four guys who
went to college to play football
uh-huh are in this like love centric
business together no it's trying to like
right I mean incredible you know one of
them went to Harvard and one of them
went to brown and I'm sure they were
like [ __ ] sees and I don't know how many
people whose lives begin on that note
end up where those two have ended up but
their whole you know their whole raise
on debt is to help people connect with
other people in meaningful ways over
meaningful topics yeah I would have
never predicted it in a million years me
to be sure both of those guys were were
definitely like the most popular guys
the best athletes but
they were never yes they were jocks but
they were never like bullies or they
didn't have that kind of bro attitude
about them they you know they were much
more mature and kind yeah then kind of
the stereotype of that but still like
it's a you know the the the terrain that
they traverse to be these kind of people
that are carrying you know such a
resonance for so many others is kind of
a remarkable thing the other thing you
mentioned that is really important to me
about the experience of TMP is that it's
super collegial and so the very things
you noted like people don't come and go
once you come and you give your talk you
stay mm-hmm you're because we're all
under a tent in a circle you can see
everybody all the time you can go sit
next to them if you want yeah
and so there's not this kind of Big Dawg
because there's no backstage and there's
no green room and that's literally true
and also kind of like figuratively true
like there isn't a separate it's not
like tada here comes rich roll you know
you just come up out of the audience and
talk for a little bit and you go back
into the audience because everybody's
learning and everybody's working it out
together and then this kind of eyes up
hands out mentality that that audience
has like I never have made so many
contacts in four days and contacts makes
it sound like I'm building my
professional network I don't have a
professional like just a writer but but
the I mean when I like I hug 50 people a
day at initech approach and like leaving
there you are you're a little bit
different and I don't know where else
people can get that yeah I think that's
very true and I think we're we're
starving for that kind of connection
well that that's the beauty of
neighborhood project which is this this
very clever way that Tom and crew have
come up with to share the TMP experience
more broadly because Nantucket is really
far away for most people and it's
expensive and it's hard to get to and so
you and you have all this all these
takeaways all this learning all this
content you have speakers who have given
really remarkable talks about ideas you
haven't heard before and then you also
have
these short films that we make so we
make tons of five to ten minute films
right and so if you can put some of that
together and then share it with people
broadly they can watch it in their
living room together with other people
and then they have set aside two hours
to talk about it that's remarkable so to
me the biggest biggest win for TMP is
this neighborhood project thing like
getting it out into the hands of many
and it's totally free how many of those
are currently up and running I think
there are 70 mm-hmm and I think we're in
26 or 27 states yeah so yeah I mean it's
it's real I went I went to one you did
Greg Renfrew Shari mark and Mark it was
really cool it reminded me kind of like
it was kind of like an AAA meeting mmm
watch these movies and then everybody's
vulnerable and sharing their reactions
yes and their experiences and it was
cool I really enjoyed it I think of it
as like somewhere at any given session
right because there's eight episodes if
you will in this first season and in any
given meeting of those groups because
I'm in - I'm in one here in Southern
California that I'm one went up in my
neighborhood at home it's it can be like
a grad school seminar where we're
talking about AI and the future and how
our kids are dealing with things in a
different way than we are and
approaching problems some
problem-solving in a different way the
things we never would have thought of
how that makes us feel do we feel like
old ladies who are incapable of
participating in the world because it's
moving so fast and we can barely get our
printer to work etcetera etcetera
etcetera and then there's super
heartfelt stuff like about forgiveness
and figuring out how to do that again
and again and again and again as life
requires so it's sort of a continuum of
like anything from as you say like a
meeting where people are trying to solve
a very urgent problem to a more
intellectual experience where you're
tying with an idea because it's been put
in front of you and you haven't really
had the chance to think about it and
talk about it in long-form yet and what
is the
the goal of these neighborhood project
what I mean what are you aiming for with
this meaningful connection to others hmm
that's it that's it and it's really
funny because I don't think anyone
believes us truly what is the hidden
agenda great I honestly I really don't
think it's sufficient for most people to
say I don't know it's like just for the
good of the order like this is what we
believe will make people's lives better
yeah and is that enough like it's sort
of funny I can feel people waiting for
like yeah but right what is this really
about and it's really about really many
people together in a room and like
letting them connect over a meaningful
topics well we need some kind of
ceremony or excuse to do that like
despite you know the technology that
we're all carrying around these days we
really are more isolated than we ever
have been and you know we don't go next
door and knock on the door and ask for
sugar and we don't know our name I mean
lots of people do but like you know we
live you know in an area where like I
really don't know the people that live
around me and reason to for us to get
together like it's not going to happen
well the thing I think is I don't even
know the people I know
mmm so there's a lot of people in my
neighborhood project in Oakland who I
would have told you I know them and then
we get in there and they start telling
me that they're the only person in their
family who continually forgives this was
one woman said I'm the only person in my
family who still forgives my brother
he's an active alcoholic and everyone
else has walked and I'm the only person
who's staying and everyone's mad at me
cuz I'm stopping him quote-unquote from
reaching rock-bottom
but she said but I can't I can't leave
them alone if I leave him it's over I
have no idea what I'll do but I'm the
only person so I thought I knew her yeah
as I appreciate on some sidelines with
over the years and like we did a
back-to-school coffee for the teachers
like that's what I thought I knew her
uh-huh
yeah there's knowing and there's knowing
and then to provide like a crucible like
an environment that's safe for people to
on that kind of vulnerable level is a
special thing yeah yes and it's um
terribly absent terribly absent because
when I do it I do it once a month in my
town I think even though I'm kind of in
this business
like I'm professionally attached to a
thing that does this this is still the
only 2 hours in the month that I am
being in this way right that parts of me
are turned on in a way that they are not
turned on like gears are turning that do
not turn but for that conversation this
is why I think everybody should be in
12-step programs because as somebody has
been you know a member of that for a
very long time like I'm acclimated I'm
used to going into groups where a whole
bunch of people sit down and you know
tell the horrible truths of their lives
and bare their souls and are open and
vulnerable and are willing to not only
put that out but also accept help and
it's such a marvelous remarkable dynamic
that I think
everybody could benefit from on some
level irrespective of whatever you know
problems you may or may not have in your
life I know I I mean I I think I
probably agree with you I'm not in a
12-step program but I do I mean I love
love I love to be like in the experience
of it and that's what it feels like
mm-hmm to be in there well let's talk
about how you infuse your writing with
that Sensibility you know because a lot
of your a lot of your work is about that
and it's you know you've been you have
you've been called these things like the
voice of your generation by Oprah and
HuffPost Porat poet laureate of the
ordinary like how does that make you
feel when you hear that those are very
lofty to the ordinary that's what I love
that because I did feel initially
self-conscious I mean 10 years ago the
middle place came out which was my first
book as a book about my dad and I both I
can't at the same time and my mom after
she read it said Kelly you know it's
very good I mean I did not find any
spelling mistakes and your grammar is
perfect now
yeah but like what about the stories
like that did you feel anything when
your ear and she said well I did but I
just kept wondering like who wants to
read about us like we're not rich we're
not poor we're not you know big family
we're not a small family we you know and
I said I don't know I don't know who
wants to read about us it's my biggest
fear is that it's too ordinary and and
then people wanted to read about us yeah
and I so when that came out when the
Huffington Post said that I thought oh
that's really validating in a way that
it's okay to just tell you're very
ordinary stories about you're very
ordinary life like I don't have you have
an extraordinary life you richer all
have an extraordinary life I do not I
have a really run-of-the-mill right up
the middle kind of life but you do too
let's be honest you live a pretty cool
life oh it's very cool I love my life
but it's not in terms of like let's say
that we were in a room together we were
back-to-back meetings at Random House
and you went in and you said well I'm
extreme athlete I'm an addict I'm a
vegan
you know I've experienced this isn't
this uh-huh and then I came in after you
and said I'm a mom I have two kids I
live in a house with my husband I make
dinner four times a week the rest of the
time we get takeout hook yes what's the
big takeaway well I mean I think that
that speaks loudly about your you know
your beautiful ability to translate the
human experience and all its mundane
'day into something that we can all
connect with and relate to like there's
this sense that you know you have to be
Hemingway in order to you know write
about your life like what are the crazy
adventures that you've gone on but in
truth like your books I mean it's like
what every book hits number two and then
you're know what's going on with that I
don't know it was with the middle place
it was three cups of tea uh-huh was just
sitting there forever I could get past
it and then another one it was like the
former Secretary of State's book was
sitting on top of mine sometimes you
just can't get but it's generally like
all these famous people and CEOs and
stuff like that right
I remember when when the book the first
book was on the bestseller list showing
it to my dad and saying okay so you know
who's on this list an NFL coach two
former presidents former Secretary of
State a newscaster like Tom Brokaw was
on a list at that time Jack Welch was on
the list at that time and I said in you
greenie you're on that list and what was
his response to that Bobby Bobby
that's great is this a crack-up yeah
it's uh it's beautiful that you can you
get to through your honesty and your
vulnerability and your amazing ability
to kind of you know find in mind the
meaning in our daily lives and translate
that in a way where where the reader can
really it just resonates with people
they see themselves in your writing they
can identify with that and I think it
makes them feel like their lives have
meaning to they don't have to be
Hemingway the nicest thing that people
ever say is exactly exactly that's
exactly it
I have have been around the edges of
that feeling and I have lived that
moment before and I've never been able
to articulate it but I've had this deep
sense that it was important that it was
like a that you know it was a turning
point or it was a pivot point in my life
and you said it exactly I watched your
video transcending the other day which
is you reading this article before group
is a group of women that's essentially
just about what it's like to be a woman
a mom you know basically the typical
kind of suburban experience and not only
did you get choked up at the end but
like all these women were just like they
were all you could they weren't saying
it out loud but they're all going
exactly exactly exactly well the the the
thing about that as I had written it for
my 40th birthday and the idea was that
there there are these this constant flow
of deposits that we're making in each
other's lives that allow us to catch
each other on the worst day so it's
let's say I'm in your life for 10 years
and I'm dropping your kid off at school
for you and then you're running my kid
home from soccer and then I share my
leftovers with you and then I cut pop
over the day you sprained your ankle and
then you come over the day my husband
gets fired and and life keeps doing what
life does and we're staying with each
other we're holding on to each other and
then something really happens then
there's some tragedy mm-hmm the only
reason why I can be there for you that I
can comfort you in that moment is
because we've been on this road together
so that was the turning point of that
idea was that there's you know a
thousand minuscule deposits that build
this foundation that we could stand on
the day the worst thing happens the day
you lose your kid the day you lose your
husband but we tend to focus on those
monumental occurrences and glance over
the minutiae but your work is really
about lasering in on those little
moments and realizing that that's really
where life takes place my favorite line
that I ever wrote in all these books is
the last line of tell me more and it's
your profoundly ordinary kid is singing
in the shower and you get to be here to
hear it yeah and in the context of that
book which was written in the wake of
losing my dad and then losing my good
friend Liz and giving a eulogy in front
of her three kids eight ten and twelve
and then going home and having my kids
get in a big fight at the dinner table
and then my daughter kind of storming
off and then she was in the shower and
then I heard something and then I went
upstairs and then I kind of leaned my
ear against the door and I heard oh the
single ladies all the single ladies mmm
and it was like I get to be here they're
like I get to listen to this kids sing
in the shower and whatever that means
for you that's what it means but for me
it was like head to toe chills like I
was so hyper aware you know how you are
after a loss and it fades and that's
partly what tell me more is about to
it's like how difficult it is to kind of
hold that
clarity and live in that space and not
return to your normal crappy self who's
pissed off about gaining weight or
getting a parking ticket but it that
moment of standing outside that door was
like Liz will not have this moment she
will not get this moment she will not
listen to her 15 year old singing
Beyonce in the shower and I'm here and
to be able to be present and aware of
the import of that which is such a
fleeting thing it's so difficult for us
as human beings to hold on to that truth
right and and that is what the book is
about it's sort of like you you know
navigating the aftermath of your father
and your friend housing away and and
grappling with your frustration or
perhaps on some level shame for not
being able to kind of you know maintain
that level of gratitude throughout like
constantly having to remind yourself but
defaulting to just the daily grind yeah
well you know it's interesting so the
the book is built around these twelve
things that I feel like we have to be
able to say to one another and to
ourselves to be adults in the world to
be in permanent relationship and the
first one is the most unusual and it's
this thing that this mindfulness guy
taught me so I was working at my
husband's I was writing at my husband's
startup it's called medium and it's a
total class see I'm still startup know I
guess so ed Williams who started it and
you know would let me come and and write
there is very generous and open the
doors to two writers in the area and so
I come and you know I was like total
classic San Francisco startup like
kombucha bar meatless Monday's nap pods
mmm
which I'm pretty sure it's like where
the Millennials are getting it on and
then they had this mindfulness guys
names will kabobs in who would be an
amazing guest for you he's Jon
kabat-zinn son right yeah who wrote at
wherever you go there you are and um so
anyway he would lead these sessions so I
just like plopped in there right
next to EV as if I was like a real
employee and this guy to do this little
talk before we meditated about it's like
this and I didn't totally know what he
meant but I felt like it resonated on
that level that like a song lyric might
resonate where you wouldn't even want to
parse it you just want to like sit with
it and hold it and put it in your wallet
and so I kept thinking about it and then
I actually ended up in a long
conversation with them and I said you
know I have these moments where I
totally lose track of what matters and I
have and I have these moments right it's
crystal clear and they're so precious
and I want to hold them and I can't and
he said it's like this and he said when
do you lose track and I said well here's
an ordinary Monday morning at our house
so I have these two kids and a husband
and they are eating breakfast at the
table and then they're very busy people
and so they don't have time to put the
dishes in the sink but I do so I take
the dishes over and I'm already like
starting to feel steamed about that and
then they're gone and then I go back to
the kitchen table where I serve this
like organic food that I buy at a
grocery store that really irritates me
and on the kitchen table is a little
teeny pile of cut toenails uh-huh and
that just took me over the edge
the indignity I mean do you have cut on
it like have you ever cleaned up
somebody's cat toenails Oh everything
has everybody cleaned up somebody's cut
toenails is that what I don't understand
about that well it's just it's just the
idea you know look kids at a certain age
it's just they just they just do what
they do and then they walk away right
and the implicit message as the parent
is always like okay so I'm here I'm the
one who's supposed to clean all this up
right it's like a daily thing yeah and
then but the only way out of course is
to realize that it's like this like that
there are that and and if you don't mind
I'll just read the end of it please
chapter because
because what I was feeling was that well
well after the cut toenail thing then I
this UPS guy came who is like
aggressively fit like you fit and I am
not fit and I do not exercise and I do
hope that during this conversation today
you can persuade me
they liked you their turn over a new
leaf I think you're doing fine oh that's
terrible it's terrible I'm gonna age so
badly anyway put a pin in that so anyway
the guy comes and he gives me this
little envelope and it's from j.crew and
then I remember that I bought this
t-shirt this little linen top and then I
realized that like linen has no stretch
in it there's no lycra but there's like
ER and almost everything else so I don't
really know what size I am anymore you
know
because maybe I'm a six but maybe I'm a
12 because I've been wearing stretchy
clothes for like fifty there's the size
we tell people that we are and then
there's the real size that we are yeah
your driver's license waiting right so
to speak
so anyway I go upstairs I put this shirt
on and then I can't literally can't get
it off and I have to cut it off with
scissors so I'm I'm fit to be tied I'm
like staring at myself and my new stupid
vest in the mirror and I relax my face I
exhale I can sole my reflection it's
like this Kelly this is how it goes
hidden in the mornings frustrations like
a rattlesnake in the woodpile is
something else I closed my eyes so I can
listen for the other thing the further
away much worse thing in the quiet of my
own head life ends
I've known this since the summer of 1972
when an ambulance drove away in silence
with the old lady down the street who
gave out almond joys on Halloween but
now I've seen mortality do it's awful
ghosting up close twice and that has
changed the context of everything in the
new zodiac without greenie my dad
without Liz all terms have been
recalibrated pain is agony bad is fatal
the scale is reset making it hard for me
to reconcile what I've seen with how I
live
Liz would have done a week of aggressive
bromodomain inhibitors at cedars-sinai
for one morning of hairballs egg shells
and toenail clippings to see her kids
become teenagers screaming obscenities
each other in the hall she'd have given
up every organ in her pelvic cavity then
there's greenie who would have told you
that life was a carnival all music and
snack stalls fortune tellers and
strongmen it's magical lovey Edward my
husband called greenie a happiness
genius but ask anyone he was as excited
about being alive as anyone you'll ever
meet this isn't just a kid making a hero
out of her dad and me
I walked next to him in that festival
light for almost 50 years and then one
night in February his hand went still in
mine and Here I am
same as ever except quicker to anger and
thirteen pounds heavier shouldn't loss
change a person for the better
forever maybe wills curious phrase it's
like this applies here to this
forgetting this slide into smallness
this irritability and shame this
disorienting grief it's like this minds
don't rest they reel and wander and
fixate and roll back and reconsider
because it's like this having a mind
hearts don't idle they swell and
constrict and break and forgive and
behold because it's like this having a
heart lives don't last
they thrill and confound and circle and
overflow and disappear because it's like
this having a life beautiful there's so
much in there and I'll talk about I know
but sad acceptance that that you are not
going to be able to hold it right that's
huge that was freedom and it releases
you from that pressure that you feel or
that guilt that you Harbor that you're
supposed to be other than what you are
yes and the self looks think that comes
with it because it is really astonishing
to stand in front of a congregation of
people and give a eulogy for a young
person and then ever be mad again does
not seem to go together like I guess I
had sky-high expectations that I would
forever
consistently and constantly be different
and you're not you're not and that's
weird it feels like you're
dishonouring this memory of this person
yeah I mean it's it's it's sort of a
comfort to hear that it's just like this
and yet it leaves me wondering well why
does it have to be this way
like why are we why is the human mind
soul spirit wired in that way like what
how is it possible that you know two
hours after some life-changing
experience you could get into a road
rage or you know distract yourself with
you know some small indignity and then
beat yourself up for it to make it even
worse so I blame our neurobiology like a
and by that I mean the way that we have
evolved as a species to survive under
the circumstances as they've changed
over thousands of years and I think it's
astonishing the levels at which we are
operating at any given moment
like I could be having this very deep
conversation with you at the same time
that I'm thinking I would like to floss
my teeth uh-huh I would like to drink
this water in front of me but I don't
want to make any noise uh-huh I hope
that reading wasn't too long for rich I
wonder if other authors do readings on
here whether I just totally bugged him
like I can hold in my head and in my
heart
simultaneously I'm gonna say two dozen
different discrete thoughts that are
operating at different discrete levels
huh that's really something to marvel at
and accept as the truth of our machine
like this is what our machine does this
is how the machine works and as much as
we can intellectually understand that
it's still the root of our suffering yes
Wells dangerous you think I'm taking a
drink now I hope it doesn't know did you
all hear that I'm sorry um hope you
heard that I bet that was my tummy I
thought I was mine yeah
right right I think about suffering a
lot as that word is so dramatic and so
apt I mean I'm not questioning it in any
way but it is incredible to me that that
is the nature of reality mm-hmm for most
people across time and across culture we
also don't calibrate it very well
like the suffering that we experienced
when you know our child does something
that irritates us isn't that different
from the emotional experience of
something that really is grave and
substantial yes well I think when I
think about you know my two am brain
like what I'm cycling on in the middle
of the night it always reveals what a
ninny I am because I honestly during the
day I'm thinking way bigger thoughts
than what's happening at 2:00 a.m. at
2:00 a.m. I'm like for instance last
night
I couldn't sleep and it wasn't for
quote-unquote the right reasons it
wasn't because I was coming here and I
wanted to make sure that I was prepared
and anything of import or that I didn't
really kill it on my brother's birthday
yesterday and maybe I should have sent
him something it was that my daughter is
running a craft camp out of my house
next week and I wondered if I had made
it clear that they are not allowed to
paint in the house uh-huh that there
should be a dry area and a wet area
that's where I was a to am nowhere
bigger nowhere more poetic or profound
just in this total quotidian space and I
just wonder like what does that mean
what does that mean about me or us or do
you have to find meaning in that right
like it's just like that mm-hmm
right right why can't you just leave it
there right why do you have to engage
with it I mean that's mindfulness right
it's just - I think is to take you
should tell me of course but it's just
to take a step back from it and watch it
flow by like a little boat on some water
can be neutral yeah not that I'm any
expert in mindfulness but I think that
they're not that's why I'm here are you
here well I'm sorry to disappoint you I
guess I want you to make me lose weight
I want you to make me better I know our
mindful that's my agenda this is now I'm
really all right well maybe that's
another podcast okay today's about you
can we have the conversion podcast where
you get me righted I don't think you
need to be righted do you don't know
maybe you need to release your your your
whatever pressure you're putting on
yourself to be righted I think you're
pretty right mm-hmm
I wish I was some had more healthy
routines yeah what's holding you back
from that love of pajamas yeah there's
nothing wrong with that deep like
there's just you know I mean I bet it's
true for many people that they're the
window I mean ideal window is the
morning right I think there's a movement
like one once I've had coffee number two
I'm a to an out each day there's a
window there where I am at my sort of
strongest intellectual capacity and I
cannot imagine trading that out for
exercise but that's also the moment to
exercise because really once you get to
eleven for whatever reason you're just
not gonna do it with yeah well if it
makes you feel better I I have this same
dilemma okay because my creative
capacities are at their best early in
the morning but that's also when I feel
like I want to train and I think in
retrospect looking back over the last
several years I think that I've created
this whole podcast as a distraction to
conveniently opt out of having to write
another book you know I only think I
really think that like writing is
probably my strength and I'm so
terrified of it that I will do anything
I'll train for some crazy ultra race or
I will spend six years interviewing
people just so I don't have to be with
myself and the written page
I totally 100% believe you like I think
this is such a common thing I mean I
think Malcolm Gladwell and Michael Lewis
and all these other big-time writers who
people want the next book from our art
would also say that this is the most
elaborate procrastination scheme man has
ever invented and I have all these
arguments to support it yeah because I
can reach more people instantly by doing
this than two years of work on a book I
agree you know so what are you well then
why do you have to write a book do I
have to write another book I don't know
according to Random House I do have to
what does that money has been accepted
and spent Oh people get out of those
things yeah time great you are cracking
a new book right now though aren't you I
am and I saw a post about that yeah I
thought no that's the kiss of death you
know if you're like now you're on the
using social media to talk about your
book that you're definitely not writing
your book you're trying to get your hit
early like you're not supposed to be
able to celebrate and like you know
across the tape with and get your high
fives until you actually have finished
your book mm-hmm but when you say then
you put something out at social media so
you can get some quick hits of like
you're doing a congratulations and it's
like you've actually done something done
anything you got all the accolade you
got all the good you know vibes yeah
without doing the work so I had written
on and I'm gonna say thirty-eight
thousand words so normal book maybe is
fifty or sixty thousand words and I
don't know I had this delusional sense
that maybe it was going to be one of
those like perfect little books that can
be really powerful for people like when
breath becomes air or even about Alice
which is the Calvin Trillin book that's
my favorite favorite example of how
powerful a small book can be and so I
put it all on social media and I sent it
off to Andy Ward at Random House who's
my editor and then I went to happen to
be in New York the following week and I
went to see him and he said it's good
it's good
I mean I'm gonna say you're halfway
mm-hmm and I mean I just deflated like a
balloon I was like half
a to say 70 just lie just say I can't go
back to work with halfway if you had
said 70 I've been working on its
afternoon uh-huh you say 50 I'm thinking
maybe I'm gonna give the money back
it was so discouraging I didn't say any
of that just so that was my own like
internal dialogue I just nodded and
tried to act like a mature writer who
could handle that kind of honest
feedback but my little like
eight-year-old inside was like anymore
where do you get the the gumption to be
so open and honest and vulnerable in
your writing any even like you know I
think that you're very free with it oh
well it's my nature
so it's not like an achievement of any
type it sound like I was one way and
then I understood something and then I
became another way to sort of how I came
out but a thing that really really
affected me was population numbers so I
remember I went traveling when I was
twenty five for a year with my best
friend from college Tracey total and she
teased me because it one of the things
in my fanny pack was this little book of
world population numbers and everywhere
we went I wanted to know how many people
live in Bangkok how many people live in
Thailand how many people haven't Sydney
how many people live in Australia and
the idea like the idea of how many
people there are was super freeing for
me like it was crystal clear and
continues to be that it does not matter
one iota what I do or what becomes of me
because there's just so many people I
couldn't possibly oh yeah there's so
many people I mean there's even so many
people who write books
there's even so many podcasts much less
like actual people on the planet pretty
soon there's gonna be as many podcasts
as there are people yeah but go ahead
yeah so I used to do this thing when I
was anxious if I was having trouble
sleeping
I would like fly around this is kind of
weird but whatever I fly around and like
lift the roof off of buildings and look
in on everybody else's life and you know
maybe next door there would be a kid you
know buying a
to propose and then the next store there
would be a man and a woman in a big
fight and then in the next room there
would be a baby being born in the next
room there would be someone taking their
last breath in front of their assembled
family and in the next room there would
be a person going crazy with because
someone broke up with them and I would
just fly around in this imaginary way
and just get smaller and personally and
that you cannot there's no sense in
holding back if that is your worldview
hmm super liberating totally liberating
and I wish it for everyone I don't I
don't think I mean I just don't think
very much matters at all yeah so do you
have to you see in terms of like risk or
right putting it out there what'll
happen if you I just can't imagine I
can't a man even even if like today but
it but it does occur to me I will say
that so like we were driving over here
and I did get a little nervous and I
thought I hope I don't screw this up and
then I was very quickly able to say what
if you do what if you totally bomb it
and you're way off point and he doesn't
like what you're talking about and it's
not a fit and they never air it and so
what right like so what car it's a day
trust me I'm the one who walks around
thinking like I'm like I'm not worried
about you but I'm man like she's amazing
am I gonna talk to her about she's
already said she's been on the Today
Show why is she coming to my house well
that's a funny thing and points to the
very true thing that can be freeing for
people is that almost everyone is just
worried about themselves yeah so me
worrying about whether I'm gonna like
show up for you and you worrying about
whether you're gonna show up for me is
the absolute truth every time at every
interaction and every scenario that
every person is in every day yeah tell
your kids that people are self-obsessed
yeah so your daughter's like worried
about her hair right for the prom and
you're like trust me every girl in
Piedmont right now is freaking out about
their hair nobody is looking I mean as
my mother used to say out for godsake
Kelly who's looking at you mm-hmm which
people always laugh and think that
that's kind of a cold thing for her to
say but I actually found it and
credibly liberating like who is looking
at you uh-huh your mom's a character
total character I was just with her for
like three nights in Philly she still
lives in the house
my dad died four years ago and she still
lives in the house we grew up in she's
been this house for 50 years Wow
she paid off the mortgage 20 years ago
oh my goodness was two hundred and
twelve dollars a month and yeah and she
just goes to church every day total
devout Catholic day every day because as
she will tell you and as my dad would be
so happy to tell you the Catholics are
the only people will show up every day
you said lovey I'm telling you you don't
think there's a rabbi out there who
would love to talk to his congregation
every day they won't show up the
Episcopalians they're not showing up you
know I don't even know the other
religions he's like the only the
Catholics only the Catholics want to
hear it every day well as much as your
mom is a character I mean your dad just
seems like not only larger-than-life but
that just the the gift of his presence
in your own life and how its kind of
informed your own path like it's it's an
amazing thing I mean it's the best thing
that could have and could ever happen to
me being born it sounds so amazing that
it makes me angry I know that that's
some people's reactions and in fact when
I was writing the middle place I kept
saying to my husband like you gotta help
me like if I'm overstating things man
you know and I said and I do think
they're gonna be people here who didn't
have an experience like this who are
gonna throw the book against the wall
and be like oh for god sake I can't
listen us for one more minute and and
Edward bless his heart would say like
this is it you've completely captured
him I mean he was what all of us would
aspire to be which is to say crazy
present he was just right here with you
nowhere else and you were the most
interesting person he ever met like he
couldn't wait he had a hundred questions
for every person standing in front of
him and he had no in my observation and
Edward has backed me up on this in my
observation he had no personal needs he
didn't need to be
heard he didn't need to be understood he
didn't need to be respected or honored
or he just was for you he's just so
interested in you and then when you left
and the next person came he was
interested in that person and he was
very easily pleased like he wasn't cool
like you know you say you have two girls
and two boys it'd be like God is that
great two boys and two girls before you
can play tennis like you know that would
be very exciting to him which is to say
that it was never I never felt like an
ounce of pressure to do anything neat to
catch his eye like he just thought I was
neat like no matter what there was it
wasn't like you can do a cartwheel
you're neat or you got an A you're neat
or you wrote a book like he the last
thing on earth he needed was for me to
be validated in some external way like
my whole life is just like lovey you're
special kid and then of course you know
he's saying the same thing to my
brothers like it's not any minute uh-huh
and so someone tells you that enough
just total unconditional love and
support and joy he liked us like he
loved us yes but he also really liked us
and that feeling like someone craves
your company you know like every time he
left the house he said lovey come with
me come on we're gonna run to the to the
grocery store come on we're and go down
to dry cleaners it's like come with me
I'll be nicer to me if they see you hmm
and he wanted me to come to work you and
everyone I met in his circle would say
Oh Kelly Kourt you're Kelly Cory boy
have I heard a lot about you huh so that
gives you this feeling like that you
have somebody on your side and that I
really wish for everyone that they would
have this sense that there was somebody
who was that on their side right so two
things I mean first of all how did that
kind of you know inform decisions that
you have made as an adult about what to
do professionally and how to live your
life like having that kind of support
system and that you know person who just
believes in you so completely I would
imagine you know is very empowering
I mean it's so woven into me
that I don't even see it as a separate
element I will respond to to not have
that yeah yeah but I will tell you this
that as I was saying before I am kind of
moving very slowly on this book that
I've way overdue on and it occurred to
me this is the first book I've written
since he died and I don't get to give it
to him and that is like like just a
little less I gotta find somebody to
give it to that it will mean something
to and and he was that person mm-hmm so
I I finally uncovered like the it's kind
of the source of my ennui with it well
you can still give it to him in a
different way and also him being
somebody who for whom you didn't need
you know external value didn't need
external validation I know but it's so
much joy I mean he was so fun like he
who come to all my book tour events like
if I was within three or four states he
was in the audience and that was really
fun because my growing up I have two
older brothers and they're both great
athletes and they're natural and kind of
everything they're good at darts and
they're good at pool and they're gonna
lacrosse and golf and tennis and
everything else that you put in front of
them they can kind of pick it up and and
I wasn't I was like the artsy fartsy kid
like making collages in the walk-in
closet like I put all the coats on the
first rack and then I would go below
like my own little narnia and I he was
sold ads in magazines so we had McCall's
magazines and Good Housekeeping magazine
it's all over our house and I would make
these super elaborate collages by myself
and I had nothing there was nowhere to
show up to like give me a round of
applause
uh-huh until I was 40 and he had so much
fun with it like being there and
watching it and watching me do my thing
and and that was fun for me I mean he's
just a very contagious kind of joy yeah
and he's just constitutionally he was
constitutionally would be that way so
the second question is like how does
that you know as a parent now
do you feel like you have to inhabit
that space or do you feel the pressure
to you know exude some of that those
characteristics that were so meaningful
for you for your own kids well I I am
super emotional person and I'm super
transparent so all that is to the good
in terms of parenting typically because
that when I'm happy it's so clear and
I'm so enthusiastic by nature so I'm
very excited about whatever they're up
to but also I'm a mom and not a dad and
I and I have daughters so it's us like a
single sex relationship and those two
factors really change it for me like I
think that I don't not sure it's
possible for a mother to be as carefree
and full of joy de vivre as it would be
yeah
for a dad yeah it's different I mean
dads and daughters yeah and and just
it's more part time in my life growing
up he was more part-time than my mom and
then so it was a big it was exciting
when he came home it was like a big
moment right and it was fun like the
whole house turned on I mean one of the
saddest things about losing him is being
in that house and having the energy be
less hmm and and it's very palpable like
we play games a lot as a family like
dominoes and hearts and Remmy cube is
our favorite and when we he was loud he
would head like a whole lot of presence
and he made dumb things super fun and
now we do the things we always did with
him without him and it's quieter yeah
and it's not as lively and we do it and
he that the absence is so profound in
especially in those moments mmm so does
that make you feel sad or just
reminiscence so sad yeah yeah well the
loss of him and the loss of your your
friend Liz really kind of inform the
book and this kind of meditation on
human connection
and the architecture of it is really
these phrases or words that you've
identified to help us kind of bridge
that gap and find a way to be more
connected to the people that are
meaningful to us so let's let's talk
about that a little bit so the the it
started at the dinner table with my
husband because we were taught who's a
man and we were talking about the
difference between saying I'm sorry and
saying I was wrong hmm and that and I
was making this passionate case as I
want to do about the humility that is
baked into I was wrong and the other
thing about I was wrong
over I'm sorry you know as just like a
superior communication is that what I
think it means is that I agree with you
fundamentally about sort of our shared
moral code like that some sort of
highfalutin but like when he said if Ed
if I if Edward and I get in an argument
and then he says I was wrong I was wrong
I feel like he came around and came back
to me and we're standing shoulder to
shoulder again and we're seeing the
world and through the same lens again
yeah everybody has this fundamental need
to be seen and when you say I was wrong
you're seeing the world through that
person's eyes you're identifying with
them and you're agreeing with them about
what is wrong and what is right like
that's the little element that hadn't
really appreciated until recently which
is like when you say I was wrong you're
saying so we agree on what's right and
what's wrong and that's wrong and we
won't do that anymore you I won't do it
to you and you won't do it to me because
it's wrong it's so hard for people to do
that I know I've gotten really good at
it
you had theirs yeah I mean and I've
learned that through recovery and it's
very empowering and I think we have this
sense that if we say that that it's
weakness or we're opening ourselves up
for attack or you know I don't know what
goes on with us psychologically that
prevents us from being able to do that
but when you do it like if you truly are
wrong and
you say it you own up to it like I was
taught you know or early and often like
if you're gonna eat crow like eat it hot
like just okay you know that's good and
it's the best way to heal and to connect
yourself to other people and to take
responsibility for your actions and make
amends and it's just the better path it
is I think a thing identified and myself
is the part of my hesitation and saying
I was wrong is if I say this then I
can't keep doing it mm-hm yeah that's
and I kind of want to keep doing I'm
selfish Brad and I want I just want to
keep doing it this way and I don't I
don't want to put gas in your car yeah
that's a good point I want to have the
right to drive your car like into the
driveway and leave you with like right
and make it your life mile worth of gas
but if I just come in and say you're
right I was wrong then you cannot do
that again
yeah I'm sorry just doesn't cut it and
I'm sorry so over you even when it's I
mean if you say it even in its most
honest iteration it still doesn't quite
cut it but it's generally used as a
sword you know oh I'm sorry
mm-hmm I'm sorry you feel that way yeah
I'm sorry that you you know don't like
what I said or whatever it is I'm sorry
you're mad yeah that's like worse well
that's not at all what I'm asking for
remotely satisfying for me in any way
hmm
so yeah so that was a good one and then
another one that meant a lot to me that
I spent a lot of time talking about and
thinking about is I don't know and the
amount of uncertainty that we are
required to tolerate is astonishing so
in that chapter I tell story about my
friend Mary Hope who worked on having a
baby for six years and there was it was
both hard for her to conceive and hard
for her to carry and so every now and
then she'd get one cooking and then
she'd lose it and then she'd go through
this whole new process and she'd go to
another doctor and all these doctors are
saying to her I don't know I don't know
I don't know and then she was finally
turned toward adoption
and they worked for some number of
really long months putting together the
documents and the legal work and then
also like the marketing brochure
anxiety's to take pictures so I took
pictures of her and her husband and her
dog in her house and her parents and
they put together this four-page glossy
and they send it to every Christian
sorority in the United States and trying
to be enough for some young mom to pick
them in the binder and then they got
their first child and then they waited
and waited and waited and they were back
in it and trying and trying and people
were using them like they would call and
say they were thinking about picking
them and would they take him out to
dinner maybe they could talk and you
know it's just really poor kids who it's
it's it's almost worth it to them to
tell the slide just to get like a free
meal yeah and then they disappear it
wouldn't be able to reach him why is
this happening to her I don't know and
then one Sunday where she's supposed to
go to Germany that morning she called me
and said I'm sitting in a hospital
holding my daughter and some woman had
picked her and I don't know why hmm and
that led her to be this certain kind of
parent that I thought was really
remarkable and and it it struck me then
and it strikes me now that she is sort
of like I don't know who this kid is
but he does but she does and I'm like
more than happy to follow along and
that's really different than the way I
was feeling about my daughter because I
was thinking like I know who you are
you're like a little bit of me and
you're a little bit of him and that's a
very dangerous point of view to maintain
and parenting which is to say that like
I know you you know and and it puts you
in a different position relative to your
kid like it creates a set of
expectations that may or may not be
foiled ultimately and there it and
regardless they're not it's not pleasant
to grow up
Saida like a bowl of expectations that
you're either foiling or meeting at any
given moment of any given day and so
that idea of like learning once and for
all as my friend did that you don't know
you don't know who you're talking to and
you don't know who's emerging in your
house and you don't know this kids so
well and then reflecting on how well
your parents did or didn't know you I
mean really my kids are 16 and 17 the
idea that I know them is so ludicrous
and all I need to do to remind myself of
that is to think about how while my
mother knew me at 17 right I mean this
is ludicrous
right so so when when one of your kids
comes to you and opens up about
something that they're going through
like how do you navigate that as a
parent even if you think you know the
answer well so that's tell me more so
that's the whole crux of the title is
that my sense my sort of definition of
love involved activism like I'm a lean
in person I'm on I want to help you fix
your problems I want to solve things for
you
I want to smooth the road and I want to
give you everything I've got like I have
so much life experience and then I also
have so much that I've learned and also
I have so much love like there's nobody
who loves these kids more than I do
nobody and there never will be I'll be
the most for sure no question and all of
that is off-limits
and all of that is problematic to the
assignment of becoming a person because
nothing could be more disabling to a kid
than to be given the answers mmm and so
and it's so hard but it's so hard to
hold back from that ah
it's impossible I mean yeah ah if she
could say like five words and I it's
like a game show for me like I'm like
I know the answer hi I can solve this
problem for you and so tell me more it
comes from my friend Tracey taro I
mentioned before I went travelling with
and she's studying to become a therapist
and she's just a very wise thoughtful
person and I have learned a lot from her
over these thirty years we've been
friends and she was doing it with her
kids she was just say tell me more what
else go on and she was holding tight to
that and it was really working for her
and she was even doing it with her
husband which I found to be sort of
amusing that like what works for the
kids sometimes works for the spouse as
well but it's of course it's true and so
anyway I that is the biggest thing is
when they come to me when I try so hard
to do is let them work it out and so my
I have another friend as if it was
actually a therapist name is Arielle and
she sort of set up this idea for me
between one end of the continuum it's
curiosity and the other end of judgment
that's a great way to look at it and so
you just want to stay as close to the
curiosity and as possible and then what
happened and tell me more and what else
and go on and and really in a perfect
interaction you wouldn't say anything
else it's like Inception because if you
can deftly sort of guide that
conversation through curiosity to this
realization point that they have then
they can take ownership over that
solution for themselves as opposed to
you kind of delivering some edicts yes
and there's two things involved in that
one is to to deliver the edict to solve
the problem is greedy and it's
wrongheaded so chances are you are wrong
about what you think the solution is
because chances are you haven't asked
nearly enough questions to know what the
actual problem is like the there's the
thing and then there's the thing behind
the thing the thing behind the thing the
thing behind the thing and so if you
haven't asked ten questions you're
solving for the superficial symptom and
not the real problem and then the second
thing is it's incredibly greedy to take
that moment of satisfaction away from
another person it would be like somebody
cooking all day and then
you coming in and taking all their tools
away from them and finishing off the
meal like no one would do that or you
know if your kid was playing a sport and
then you ran in at the last second shot
the goal like that's a terrible thing to
do it's so blatantly terrible in other
scenarios but we're doing it all the
time to each other in real life right
I'm gonna and it's like like my metaphor
for the pacing of these conversations
because I get like energized by a
problem I'm really psyched to like
figure it out with you and then I think
about like a jewelry box with tons of
stuff all tangled up in the bottom and
like what what the appropriate pacing is
for that activity is like pulling super
slow and like spreading it out in front
of you and seeing if you can discover
like the source and maybe you on clasp
on and you can slide it out an inch but
then you see that's wrapping tightly
around a ring and then you got to move
the ring and then like that's how slow I
need to be in the moment when my husband
or my girls start to tell me some
problem is like that slow yeah and that
is not my nature I tried to practice
this the other day
uh-huh my 15 year old he just met
Malthus is going through some you know
type of drama with her friends and and
I'm just delighted that she actually
wants to talk to me about anything
because as you said life you know these
are these these are not as regular as
they once were yeah and you know her
current state of evolution and I'm just
like please tell me more please you know
tell me more tell me more tell me more
and I think I ultimately kind of I
didn't like try to solve the problem for
her but I was like well maybe think
about this or did you consider this yeah
so I feel like that might have tipped
into I probably could have just much
more questions hey maybe I mean I think
I eat I empathize my
way more you than the person I'm
describing but no yeah I think that I
mean a thing I do sometimes that I feel
kind of good about because I feel like
it's so loving I mean not only do I know
that it's coming from a super loving
place but I feel like if someone did
that to me I would feel like wow what a
loving thing is that I might come back
two days later and say what's thinking
about you
I will seem at that thing you were
talking about I wonder if maybe that
directed up uh-huh
and to me I coach lacrosse in the spring
I coach I'm the assistant JV Lamaze
coach at my high school yeah and a thing
that I do a lot is I'll come into
practice and I'll say Carly come here
for a second I was thinking about your
game the next thing for you like in the
video game of your lacrosse experience
the next step for you to go from level
six to level seven is you got to lower
your top hand because you're not getting
any whip on the ball Beauvoir whatever
it whatever little thing but coaching
and parenting are different but the idea
that someone was thinking about you
after the fact that they did they
weren't just so excited to dismiss your
problem and go back to their own loving
like if I call you in two days and say
hey rich are we talking about the people
you should have anything I thought of
somebody for you don't know what like
that feels really yeah like somebody's
holding you or carrying you or walking
with you in a way that I would think
would be comforting hmm but I I don't I
mean I really have no idea what my kids
think of me to be honest I don't know if
they secretly find my advice wise and
salient or if they think like she's
batshit crazy and you know the world
gives her way too much credit and like
don't bring that nonsense in here like I
have no idea how do they feel about you
writing about them so honestly well I
mean they're teenagers so they're like
basically like living inside a lampshade
with mirrors all the way around like
it's just me me me and more me so they
don't they're not even that aware of me
as a writer like they're so in their own
lives that it's not super important to
them but then every now and then there's
like a little signal that maybe
this means something to them like they
will Georgia just graduated from high
school there was a little dinner for her
friends and all of their families and a
couple dads got up and gave toasts
whatever and then and I didn't quite
know what to do and I was I mean I'm I'm
inclined toward a toast and generally
and and I'm Irish and that's what we do
and there's a little greenie in that
there's a little grainy in that for sure
for sure and but but also a super
feeling super emotional and I was like I
think if I get up the chances of me not
crying are almost a zilch and I don't
know how she's gonna feel about that
like whether that's gonna be moving to
her or just like God mom what is your
problem and so anyway finally she looked
over at me and was like are you gonna
give a speech uh-huh and I was like oh
she wants she wants me to and so I
popped up and I sobbed through the whole
thing but it was in that moment I was
like oh she does like this part of me or
this is not horrifying to her that I
would stand in front of people and have
something to say it's interesting I mean
my daughter's just like they don't want
like I can't even take a photo of them
like they're constantly snapchatting all
day long selfies to their friends and
keeping up their streaks and whatever it
is that they do in that mysterious
another world but if I you know want to
take a picture of my daughter at her
12th birthday party it's like yeah it's
funny and and so you know I've had to be
circumspect about what I share you know
publicly about them and because it's
it's it's not there do they they didn't
make the decision for me to have a
podcast or ebooks and have some kind of
social media presence yeah respecting
out is super important but I've
sometimes what I do to make the right
decision this little game I play with
myself is would this be a good opening
salvo in therapy for them later oh wait
they say that's a jarppi and say my dad
was really famous and he put put posted
pictures of me without my permission and
he did it for five years this is a
running joke with with Malthus like
everyday like
this will be the thing that you pre have
bent they're like constantly you know
and it probably will be may you know and
that's a that's some humble pie to eat
and that's okay ya know and and trying
to do this dance around her adolescence
and try to avoid stepping on those
landmines is like an impossible task but
yesterday I was telling you
Shia are younger want our youngest had
her it was your 12th birthday and as a
parent who has you know helped raise
boys that are now grown and out of the
house and now having this 15 year old
who's almost 16 12 is just it's such a
precious full time where there's
innocence and joy and it's simple but
you know you're inching up against that
moment where it's gonna change and I
have this joke with Malthus when she was
younger like okay like I hear all this
stuff happens when you're 13 14 15 like
it's not gonna happen to you right like
no daddy you know of course it happened
so now I'm doing this with giant but I
was able to be so present and
appreciative of what was happening
yesterday because I know I know these
things change right and that's not
unlike the underpinnings of this book
for me which is I know that being here
is not guaranteed I did it I saw it I
said the words I stared right at those
kids I watched the whole thing happened
seven years she fought this thing and so
wanting to be able to hold that right
that you know something but still you're
gonna be mad at her like later tonight
oh yeah it's already happened right
right right and this it's like something
to deal with yeah it's like this it's
like this it's like this yeah another
one that I like that I feel like we're
sort of getting to anyway is onward
mm-hmm which for a while I had as oh
well because that's a huge thing that I
say to myself all the time is you know
like if something is a flop or if I
missed something or I screw something up
that the it takes me a minute but I
always find like oh well no well
hmm and then but I what I wanted to talk
about in the chapter the stories I
wanted to tell were a little bit bigger
than that we're about loss and divorce
and but even my divorced friends say
that there is this oh well moment that
they have to say okay oh wow
like that's what happened right we tried
he cheated we tried again he cheated
again I left I've been in there at like
oh well like didn't work out like I
can't live there forever I can't live in
the hot mess of that forever I gotta
move onward and so then I came to honor
and I felt better about it but I do
think that that's I mean I believe that
if you cannot say that you are [ __ ]
right well you craft this narrative
about what your life is and it becomes a
victim story mm-hmm and then the
retelling of that time and time again
becomes an entrenched identity that
prevents you from growing and you know
transcending that situation which in
truth is just something that happened
and the meaning of which is you know
only that which you give it right which
is negotiable
the meaning is negotiable with you you
you can relitigate the meeting running
but I feel like so many of us most of us
are stuck in stories that don't serve us
and we really just we live our lives
reacting to you know these events that
happen in the past to which we've
attached so much important yeah yeah I
was just with my best friend from
growing up her name's Allison and she
lives in New Hampshire and she's a she's
a rich roll fan and exercise enthusiast
hey Allison and and we were talking
about the desire to for consistency and
how you want your story to have a
certain shape and so you inflate parts
of it that help make it seem like kind
of this inevitable path mmm and that it
wouldn't it be so wonderful if people
could tell the story of their life in
the way that was more true to the kind
of
ulis unfolding of this thing where I
don't know 30% of it has nothing to do
with Who I am right now but but I want a
hundred percent of it to take me there I
want to cross I want to have this lead
to that which led to that which led to
that like it's like the first-aid
syndrome or something where you're like
well I went to Stanford and got an
organizational development to grow and
then that led to working at Bain and now
I'm starting my own consultancy you know
it's like yeah and also there were ten
other jobs in there like I'm constantly
telling my kids about dead ends like
abject failures like I got 1090 on my
SATs and I got into one college uh-huh
and I am so happy that I have that story
to tell them that because I was a
photographer I was a creative director
of an educational software company I was
a little entrepreneur for a couple years
making CD ROMs to help kids learn
Shakespeare I got a master's in English
at night for a couple years at San
Francisco State I worked for United Way
for 10 years like it doesn't add up it's
not a straight line and I want everybody
to be more honest about that
and resist this temptation to clean up
your narrative so that it feels more
linear and logical yeah because I think
we're doing each other a huge disservice
when we don't share like the dead ends
yeah I struggle with this a lot and I'm
interested in your thoughts on this as
somebody who you know gets up on stages
and you know sort of has to recount your
story hmm I now have this one talk that
I do that's like an hour long and I've
done it a million times and and I don't
know that I can do it anymore like I get
up and I tell and I was like it's even
true like what do you wait where where
am i deluding myself here and and I'm
just bored of it and I don't think it's
honest
Nessus I mean it is honest this is the
facts of this is what happened and all
of that but there's so much more and I
feel like I don't know like I've become
intolerant of it because I think that
there is so much messiness in there and
that's where the real meaning and the
beauty is right and I think as a writer
like the
you're writing about your own life and
in the in the process of doing that your
life and your your writing informs who
you like it I'm sure it gives you
clarity absolutely look back I'm like oh
now I understand something I even really
understand and when I get up on stage
and talk about it it continues to reveal
itself to you and I think that's a
really cool thing but you have to catch
yourself I know right like when you're
just up here I've told the story a
hundred times why am I telling this
story why did I first tell this story is
this even really important eight well
there's so much pressure either real or
perceived that's coming from the
audience right they want something they
want something definitive they want
something with a certain shape they want
an arc they want a little resolution and
whether they really do is another
question and a really important question
because maybe it's you and me in the
audience and the thing we'd love the
most is the story that doesn't have the
right shape that doesn't have a
resolution but there is this feeling
that like you can't just get up there
and tell them what a holy mess it's been
you gotta like give them something like
we got it's like there's this thing
called civic uplift which is I think
it's a term from journalism which is
like don't scare the people don't tell
the people too much about like the FBI
or the CIA or the Chinese government or
Tiananmen Square or whatever like
getting him some of it but you got it
you got to close that article with like
a little something to keep him to have
him hold on I mean if people knew how
corrupt or how nefarious certain things
were these institutions that were
counting on what would become of us I
mean what would this the Civic spirit
would just die and I feel that
requirement
I feel the civic uplift requirement and
I totally relate to telling a story so
many times you're not even sure it's
true anymore like there have been taught
you know the first book the middle place
was really about this cancer stuff and
then it just was an excuse to really
tell these stories about my dad and look
at what it means to be someone's kid
when you're a kid and what it means to
be someone's kid when you're all grown
up though
like the real other thing I want to talk
about but in order to talk about that I
had to tell this story of finding a lump
in the bath with my girls and then
discovering that it was cancer oh my god
at Stage three oh my god I'm in
chemotherapy a week later and losing my
hair and letting the kids shave it and
and all those beats I mean if you tell
the same story some number of times I
don't know how many times it is yeah you
can do gosh over into you can't feel it
anymore and a huge thing that I was
super afraid of with Tommy Moore was to
lose touch with the feelings especially
about Liz and her family and I have not
yet so it's only been out for the
hardcover came out last year the
paperback just came out but that would
be the saddest day that would be a
terrible terrible terrible day and then
the third thing I would say is you
should totally stop giving that speech
and you should totally stop doing this
yeah it's fine you're done you did it
and if they want to see it I'm sure it's
on YouTube somewhere and I don't know if
you knew would be an incredible
assignment it would be an incredible
self assignment to say what as of this
moment you know like totally up to speed
to this moment and all my experiences
and interactions what is the most useful
thing I could tell the world and then
how is the most useful way I could do it
that would be a great challenge right
well I'm guessing it's not the thing
you've been doing that you've done a
hundred oh no no no I mean and you know
life goes on it's sort of like a story
I've been dining out on for far too long
at this point anyway I guess although I
do want to like leave a little room for
a thing being useful to others that is
no longer no longer useful to you well I
think it's it's not about abandoning the
story completely but it's about finding
it another way a unique lens on it you
know because it's like I've learned how
to be vulnerable and be honest and
connect with an audience and then take
them on you know a three-act journey
that leaves them feeling empowered and
capable but I've just done it in a
certain way for
very long time that now feels stale but
it may not feel stale to an audience I'm
sure if that's the thing hey you know so
so is it selfish of me yeah I mean like
yes then it's indulgent oh I want to I
want to do you know it's like the you
know we don't want to hear you play the
hit you know you're gonna like play your
experimental jazz dude you're Paul Simon
play it but I mean back to you in the
book I mean I think you know look your
your your your gift is in storytelling
and this book is sort of like a
self-help book
we're getting people like look these are
these are certain things that you can do
that you can incorporate into your life
that will allow you to more deeply
connect with other people but you do it
not by here's your listicle at the story
connecting you know people through
storytelling and by sharing your innate
vulnerability and like the things that
you go through again back to where we
kind of opened this it's like this is
how people are able to like see their
own journey through the lens of your own
personal story I mean it's very exciting
to be an observer like a like a fine
observer that's that's really what I
think that writing has created an
interest and a capacity in me to be
super tuned in partially in a just a
very very practical level like I need
stories and so I have to look for them
and then partially in this miraculous
way they're just they just pop up
everywhere there's always it's always
right there and that's when I discover
all the time like even just I mean I
could make a story out of today easily
easily just a moment of like having your
daughter telling your daughter to turn
off the rap music and really saying
what's on your forehead and there's
paint on her forehead like just the idea
that there's a fifteen-year-old while
we're in here there's a fifteen-year-old
like listen
a chance the rapper and throw and paint
all over around five feet away from here
this is that's the story like I and so
to be tuned into your surroundings in
that way that's really what I am working
on the most that's mindfulness that's
presents president oh if you're paying
attention
nothing's boring that's right right
that's right that's right and yes but
that's a skill as well like one that
you've clearly finely attuned well if
it's a skill that's good news for
everybody because that means it's
available to be developed in all of us
rather than some gift from above you
know I love those Angela Duckworth
concepts about growth mindset and fixed
mindset and you know I completely
believe that because I have written
these books and because I've written so
much for short form stuff for magazines
that I have refined like I'm developing
a skill and I am nurturing it and I'm
giving it my 10,000 hours mhm and it's
giving back I mean it's a super virtuous
circle and it's just more satisfying I
mean I'm just more like a day has way
more potential now because I'm super
tuned in right and then the other piece
is that if you are if you've got totally
gotten over yourself and you have this
sense of like everyone's interesting
then you can really have a big day yeah
the world completely opens up to you yes
and that's really the lesson of my dad
and it's also the lesson of the
neighborhood project is like you don't
know who you're sitting next to like
cool it with the thin slicing you don't
know you don't know her there's so much
more inside the people that you're right
around you than you're aware of and if
you can inhabit that humility and
approach things that way as my dad did
as we do in the neighborhood project as
writers do then you're like on the hunt
then then you have this point of view
that's like what do you have like tell
me more what do you got you got to drop
the mask and your defenses I now allow
yourself to be open
and you know we're so we're living these
crazy fast-paced lives we barely have
time to say hello to the barista at
Starbucks and on to the next thing and
people are served obstacles disposable
obstacles like in the path of us just
getting through the day yes and that the
big thing I'm having a lot of fun with
is mono tasking which is just another
way of having presents but like I had
soul is my friend but also my friend
Christy moves in this certain way that I
have observed like when she's making tea
she's just making tea and when she's
sitting with you and eating a bowl of
pasta she's just eating the bowl of
pasta and sitting with you uh-huh and
that's not true for me like I was
playing about a crazy person right first
it was like totally getting off on like
I'm putting away laundry while talking
on the phone while like swiping dust
bunnies against the baseboards of my
house with my socked foot like that was
that was like winning for me was doing
those three things at the same time and
that is losing it is totally losing like
it can be deeply satisfying to swipe the
dust bunnies off your wood floor if you
could just say I'm going to mono task
now right now I'm just gonna do the dust
bunnies later I'm gonna sit on the phone
and talk and I'm not gonna do anything
else I'm just gonna talk to Christy on
the phone you know I never relief
because you're like I'm just gonna do
one thing and yet it's also seemingly
impossible yes but I feel like I'm
getting better at it you are yes like I
can cook now I mean I'm not a cook with
my kids were here they'd be like you
know how to cook which I don't I'm not
very good because I'm impatient but the
I can like boil pasta now and just boil
the pasta and like not touch my phone
and not turn on the TV and not like flip
through a magazine or catalog while I'm
waiting for the pasta I could just sit
there and I am trying to do this more in
front of my children because this these
[ __ ] phones are so omnipresent it's
tragic
mm-hmm it is tragic I was just with
Georgie yesterday we had to fly all day
from the east coast to the west
and I was with both of them and it was
like there's only the phone there isn't
like I have I I see you have a notebook
and a pen like I'm a notebook and a pen
person myself I like to draw my
calendars and and put that I do them in
that's hardcore rows of four and put it
in that way and like you know color out
the travel days and put little arrows
and like little clouds on people's
birthdays and uh-huh
all that and I find that the attending
to that attending to my upcoming
schedule in that way by hand has this
focusing effect and that you could not
have on a phone yeah I agree and I have
my own you know trials and tribulations
with my relationship with my phone but
I'm you know deeply concerned about my
kids my daughters and the way that they
interact with it and and I often find
myself at a loss as to how to
effectively parent through that because
I can just see it happening in front of
me and on some level like I'm on my
phone too much so
okay I'm mirroring this behavior I'm
creating a permissive environment for it
so Who am I to then erect these rules
around it and yet the the rampant sort
of you know it's just like zero boundary
relationship that my 15 year old has
with it leaves me like very scared I had
a I had this um I'm big on like
propaganda campaigns like parenting
through propaganda so and I've totally
been exposed now but I you what I used
to do was like say things with an ear
shot of them so I'd say oh I love that
Marga brer I mean I just looked over at
her she's just reading her book with her
feet up there's no phone in sight blah
blah you know like trying to lay it on
really thick and then George is like mom
I know you're saying that because I'm
sitting here and you want me to get off
my phone sounds like okay I got I got to
be sneakier
yeah and way too transparence yeah I
know I know
it worked for a minute like when they
were like eight uh-huh that was kind of
motivating but I do think
I wish if I could go back in time I
would have total rules like I would say
that you can't have your phone in your
bedroom imagine that that would be huge
I don't know if you could hold that line
though I would say there's no phones at
our dinner table which is true and we
don't take phones when we go out so
that's good that's the only boundary we
have and I feel I've done them a
terrible disservice hmm we've had a
moment where we Edward and I got
together and we like ginned up our
courage and we were like we are gonna
fight this war we are gonna say at
certain at 8 o'clock every night we put
our phones to bed 1 2 3 4 and they just
sleep in their little bed together you
know remember all that there's like
somebody's big idea that lasted like you
know a couple weeks oh my got two nights
yeah
two night cuz I rose like I have to do
this I have to do this I'm like oh boy
here we go yeah there's the [ __ ] I know
they're gonna climb through that really
sword and once the pattern is you know
once the they've established a certain
relationship with it - like backtrack
against that is another thing I tried to
do is just improve what was on their
phone so I'm I'm always showing them I
love Instagram and I love my feed
because I have National Geographic and I
have I have the onion which i think is
totally hilarious and so I have this
cool flow of animals doing weird things
beautiful sunsets etc very very funny
onion headlines and then some friends
and I think maybe the the effect I might
have on you is to say look I know you're
gonna be on this thing forever why don't
you put some things in front of your
eyeballs that are gonna make you feel
differently mmm first of all thank you
violates the tiny moral I know I know I
know right it's like laden with advice
and judgments god damn it it's not easy
but you know snapchat I'm like why again
you can everyone can laugh now
cue the laughter I'm about to expose
like
idiotic pipe dream of mine snapchat it's
so weird to me because for one minute I
was on snapchat so I could snap chat
with them I'm trying to like get in
their line of sight and but then they
would just they just sent a picture of
themselves yeah and I think why don't
you send a picture of the world you're
in like even if you're at the
supermarket like send me a picture at
the supermarket or your honor run send
me a picture you're on or you're with
your friend Jenny like take a picture of
you and Jenny but snapchats just a
series of weird pictures of yourself so
there's no information there's nothing
to connect about there's I don't know
anything new about you for having seen
that it's just this like tyranny but
Kelly the whole point is that you're not
supposed to understand it and this is
part of what it means to be growing
older it's clearly a generation gap
because I go through the same thing and
and it's about streaks yeah like just
like tap your it well you know have you
seen that there's people I don't know
where they are I think it's at Apple who
were young and were engineers and we're
building this all around neuroscience
and they know exactly how to get you
hooked and then those people got married
and then they had children and then this
children became teenagers and then these
people were horrified at what they had
done and now they're trying to like
unravel it yeah but you know total
Pandora's but the pockets that I just
put up last night is with a guy called
Cal Newport who's a professor of
computer science at Georgetown and he's
written he wrote a book called deep work
that's amazing about how to you know
sort of be productive and a distracted
world and his newest book is called
digital minimalism and it's all about
this mmm-hmm and all the science and
psychology and money that's been
funneled into these devices to addictive
and to sort of hijack your attention and
the downstream impact of that like on
how we're functioning as a society and
it's a it's a pretty it's a it's a dire
picture but there is agency and we just
have to be more diligent about erecting
boundaries between
these things that entice us right and
it's a weird kind of cultural phenomenon
that we're in right now where we're
seeing young people embrace minimalism
not just with you know their digital
devices but in all regards yeah and
people who are who are choosing
experience over salary and you know
there is a real interesting shift and
not just Millennials but the you know
the generate the generation behind them
in terms of like how service-oriented
they are and how its impact that
motivates them and that's very different
from when we were kids so despite the
kind of apocalyptic you know sort of
picture that we can paint with these
things I see like a lot of I get a lot
of hope and inspiration from that
particular type of mindset yeah I mean
it's that the my friend Meg works for
LinkedIn and they have all this research
about this generation and how much
they're willing to give up in the name
of purpose and mission and deeper work
but the thing I see with my kids is like
you know there's a whole bunch of like
monkey mind type thoughts where you're
hopping between apps and you're watching
TV and then you're looking down and
you're doing everything at once and then
there's long thoughts like long slow
thoughts like the kinds of long slow
thoughts you have when you're reading
and so the antidote is reading but I
think that the poison of smartphones is
that they make long thought and mono
thought much more difficult yeah because
I think it's a skill that atrophies you
and I think you have this yeah you have
to go way out of your way to just be
bored and I were to do what you do you
have to have extended rumination periods
you have to be able to think and be
alone with yourself and all of that and
that's very much been eroded and when
you're doing that because you're so used
to like being productive quote-unquote
and like setting them up and knocking
them down and
like you are with your phone and then
you switch to like a manuscript the
feeling of like this is glacial progress
is so pronounced yeah I mean if it just
it just feels like a complete waste of a
day I know in 20 years like what are the
books that are gonna be coming out right
you know half a page
Andy Ward says short is the new line
yeah well I hope this pendulum you know
let's listen the pendulum always swings
back let's hope that it does and I think
you know podcasting isn't is an antidote
to that like you know who who would have
thought people would listen to to our
conversation I yet they do they do
because it goes back to storytelling
really I think and this innate hardwired
need that we have to connect with other
people through their testimony and their
stories and podcasting really fills that
in a world in which we've been
programmed to just watch sound bites and
five-second views it is you're right
it's like a leading indicator podcast
the interest in podcasts and success of
podcasts and the success of long-form is
like a really positive indication that
there's there's a persistent need that
will win the day and I'm sure there's
there's you know your husband and EV
could speak to this as well in terms of
the success of medium because the medium
is all about long-form as well yeah you
know isn't that clever how I've Williams
like started Twitter I know and reduced
us all to 140 characters and he's like
that's crazy we need space right time I
think we the other uh-huh I became like
a thing like it's interesting to reflect
back on the evolution of that because we
went through that period where it was
all about bloggers and blogging and wait
now nobody blogs and you know it's
podcasting now for the moment and
YouTube and all these other things but
if you want to write a thoughtful
long-form piece you don't have to have a
blog and put it on your website try to
draw attention to you you put it on
medium yeah where everyone else can find
it you go where the eyeballs already are
so I love what he's built there ya know
I'm really encouraged by medium yeah
well we gotta round this
here what do we have we're almost at two
hours um let's get to go potty
do you me too is that what cuts this
thing off generally someone is like you
have to go the bathroom we just add it
we added it you want to go no no no um
I'm not in a hurry though okay we can
keep talking yeah back to back to
storytelling and back to back to the
book I mean what what is it that you
want people to really get out of this
latest work well I have this vision
always when I'm writing that I want them
to finish the book and like clap it
together and kind of weave it and say
this is totally worth every minute like
I don't think it's a small thing to read
a book and I think even really
thoughtful people don't read that many
books in a year you know I don't know
what percentage of America reads a book
a month but I bet it's not much and so
I'm asking you to do something that's
quite unusual and so I want so much for
you to feel like it was like worth every
minute now that being said like people
tell me they read tell me more like in
an afternoon which is awesome to think
that they couldn't put it down but it's
also like it did take three years right
yeah it's a little funny that this is
like something to keep them company
while the laundry dries but anyway I
just want them to feel like it was time
well spent the time in the pages was
well spent
I want them just smile a lot yeah I like
it when people say they got emotional I
mean I just like it that it moved people
if maybe there's like one more minute of
presence and consciousness and and
hereness that you would get because you
read it that'd be great
I do feel like it's a very cool service
to provide to name things that are like
slightly difficult to name for people
you know I like the snap your finger
moment like yes
yes that that that feels like that
moment of identification yeah and like
thank you like that's exactly what I was
feeling and I've been trying to say it
and understand it and and and you like
help me cross the finish line on
something that's very satisfying hmm so
any and all of that would be a win for
me on that subject of this desire to
have people kind of read it and close
the book and just go that's so good
and you tell this story I heard you tell
this story about you have in mind these
two friends of yours that respect Tracy
and technique that you keep in mind I do
when you're writing they're crazy
Johnny of what they would be feeling
when they're reading your book yes so my
husband went to business school at
Stanford with this guy Doug Lane and
he's really bright and he's a great
reader and I think he probably reads 20
books a year and his wife is equally
bright and so I always picture them in
bed and Tracy's got one of my books open
and Doug looks over and says how is it
and then I have this horrific feeling
that she's gonna be like okay you know
like kind of like a lover but and that
makes me want to work way harder like
you know there is the kind of intended
reader or whatever but if I could an
Edward you know and I think a lot about
Edward like I'm I mean I do have this
sense that I'm like representing him out
there and I don't want to make a fool
out of myself and as much for my own
sake us for his like I don't want his
wife to be this ass who rates these
shabby books that are you know she whips
him off mmm for his own say you know I
want him to feel like he's perfectly
happy to be known by this or involved in
this whole enterprise right and so
there's always a moment with every book
where I say okay you can read it and you
have to tell me you have to protect me
you have to say it's not ready yet
because a lot of people in the system in
the publishing system have too much work
yeah and they might not say it's not
ready yeah they might let it go cuz
they're they're working on 20 bucks
these guys like good beats less is good
right there yeah and then you know I'm a
B student to be honest like I didn't I
wasn't a grinder I'm very sane as we've
discussed like I know that this doesn't
matter on any cosmic or even microcosmic
level and so it's hard for me to get
wrapped up around the axle and stay up
until 4:00 in the morning like wrestling
a sentence to the ground but then I do
have these like peak moments where I say
to Edward or to Andi Ward at Random
House like don't let me off easy yeah
like give me the real business like make
me work harder well your your works are
so deeply personal that you know the is
like a strike through the heart it's not
like you're writing some antiseptic book
about a subject matter that you research
like this is you and your life yeah
right it's so personal and so I wonder
whether you know this idea of having
people in mind and wanting it to be this
for others like that can be very
paralyzing like I know for myself like I
can't I can't think about those things I
have to just write what feels right to
me in a vacuum like I can only be I I
have to be the the audience of it yeah I
start thinking about other people I'll
start you know editing myself or being
circumspect about things ordinarily that
I shouldn't that don't serve what I'm
trying to excite us yeah I am there's
almost always somebody extremely
important that a that a book involves
that I could never not be thinking about
so and tell me more like you know Liz's
husband Andy and her kids we're super
important to nail it for did you let
them read parts of it before it yeah I
mean yeah for sure for sure but the idea
that this I mean that that's both super
freeing and deeply satisfying is like
maybe I just wrote it for them maybe was
just for them and and if it helps
it'd be 1% less awful then I'm I'm done
right and and it does I mean it's it's
you know I know I know because now I've
lost somebody even though it was a
totally fair time it was an old man and
you know was perfect out but still I
love it when people bring him up and so
when you write a book and you put
somebody's mom in there and you're
talking about her over and over again
and then she's in the world and that's
really meaningful to them so it's
someone still deep in your own
relationship with that person beyond the
grave yes oh for sure for sure I mean
you know mostly I think about her I mean
mostly I think about what she was robbed
of not so much like what I can continue
to relate to with her but more just like
I can't believe you don't get to be here
I cannot believe that I am like hugging
your child and you can't do it mmm I
can't believe I'm looking at your child
like I'm looking at this kid her son
looks so much like her and he's a
whirling dervish she never stops moving
super kinetic great athlete and just
just never seen still and every now and
then when I'm with them he stands still
and we stare at each other and he knows
what I'm doing and I know what I'm doing
and maybe she knows too but I mean we
are right she is right there what do you
do when you get stuck writing yeah I put
it away and I go like clean cabinets I
mean I get stuck all the time like it's
yeah exactly it's more ordinary for me
to be stuck than to be in flow like so I
mean you know it's interesting I've been
thinking a lot about talking about work
and talking about the thing you're
working on and whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing I had heard a
writer say once that they never talk
about it because part of the reward of
having written is being able to finally
share it and talk about it and if you
give yourself that reward prematurely
you're less motivated to complete the
work
and I think there might be something
like that for me which is to say that I
totally relate to you thinking maybe
I'll just podcast forever like why write
a book like this is so satisfying and
this right now is so satisfying for me
like I could do this all day long and
way more satisfying than writing right
I'm only glad to have written I'm almost
never happy when writing I think that
that is very honest and probably the
experience of most writers I guess right
now like it's so I'm my most happiest
when I'm writing feels maybe that's true
for certain people I mean I'm a total
expert so there's no way I could be
happy being alone huh your favorite part
is the books done and now I get to go
out in the world and tell everyone about
it hon ever since I never sent that's
all I want yeah I just want to start
conversations like that's right you know
who wants to be pulling their hair out
like at the kitchen table working on one
paragraph for six hours and there's just
so much failure there's so much failure
in writing like that there's this
success rate is like 5% or sometimes
just really really small it's almost
nothing in my life has prepared me for
this much consistent relentless failure
which is to say like I can read way
above the level I can write and that
it's never lost on me that I am NOT able
to achieve what's a Marilyn Robinson is
able to achieve or jessamine Ward who
I'm reading right now or Lorrie Moore
and you know I have a master's in
English literature I was an English
major like I understand the difference
between literature and what I'm doing
and I love what I do you know and I love
am Lamont and other people who do what I
do and that that whole genre I think
it's really useful but I know that it's
not
I mean if I had the IQ of like a Marilyn
Robinson if I could let me talk about
like a person who's able to hold a slow
complex thought and like develop it I
mean I can barely read it okay it's just
at the edge of my intelligence level to
be able to read it and process and
understand it and so I'm always seeing
that Delta which means that I'm
inevitably failing at some level and
that's something to process you got to
do something with that sense of it and
you got to say yeah yeah that's the
feeling again or you like look it is
like looking in the mirror like some
days you look in the mirror and you're
like I'm cute I look alright and other
days you're like I cannot believe I've
ever been kissed like I am atrocious I
have age spots and wrinkles in my neck
has dropped into a wattle and my
shoulders are sloped and my belly sticks
out and it's just horrific and then the
next day you know bad not doing too bad
and it's just like that with your
writing like you open it up and you
think oh that's good that's a good
paragraph like the thing I read I really
like still liked it and then I could
have opened to another page and read it
and thought like I cannot [ __ ]
believe if I put that in print okay I'm
just stuck with that forever that my
name is attached to that [ __ ] you know
and it's all within the same book it's
out other than the same experience is
like you might get one one beautiful
passage in in a hundred pages and one
more something lovely something that you
would be so happy to be known by hmm in
the middle of some stuff that's good
it's good like it to be it's definitely
a B b-plus I'm really selling the hell
out of my [ __ ] here 'he's the thing i
mean it depends on how you define good
writing like i read your book and i'm
and i and i go i can't i can't do what
she does like I can't like the the
manner in which you're able to take the
ordinary and the mundane and the very
personal and translate it into a way
this just it just makes you feel warm
and fuzzy makes you feel loved it makes
you feel comfortable and at home and it
makes you feel seen and there's a gift
in there some kind of special sauce that
you have that may not be
you know that which these luminaries
that you regard do but they don't do
what you do right I know right and
that's just staying and you know that's
just saying you know let's just all
bring our gifts forward and see how it
works out right so is that the advice
that you give to aspiring writers and
young people that want advice from you
yeah I mean and one thing that I think
is very funny and relatable is that many
many people who say asked for advice
about writing I will say do you right
now and they say no and I said well then
my first piece of advice is you should
write the secret to writing is writing
yeah like it would be like me saying
like I really want to run a marathon and
you something do you run right no and I
don't even okay well I'm a dark I know
step one for you kid so I do think that
there's something there's it's like a
magical aspiration that many people hold
secretly or not that they want to write
a book someday but I think many fewer
people actually have the intention
mm-hmm and and are actually taking steps
in that direction once I know someone's
taking steps in that direction then I do
think it's kind of fun to try to help
them find it you know to find some kind
of voice that's different and it's
theirs and I think most people are super
hung up about how they sound on the page
and I feel like the goal is to sound
more or less like yourself for me for
the kind of writing I do I mean if I
were writing a novel it would be very
different but I'm not using voice in a
specific way like that to achieve some
artistic end I'm trying to just give you
give you it as I feel it as I experience
it in my voice and the so the thing I do
is just read it out loud and if it
sounds like me if it sounds like
something I would almost say you know
maybe on a really good day when I was
hyper articulate but still within the
range of something I might say then it
can stay then it belongs there then it's
gonna be it's gonna flow in your ear and
that a thing that is said to me
sometimes that feels very
validating is oh you talk to suck you
eat you talked just lucky right right
and I think that's good then I wasn't
false I didn't like you know flour it up
too much and I didn't try to sound
smarter than I am and I think the the
mistake that gets made with that is that
people think that means it's easier but
it's actually harder wait I got way all
right
why aren't ya cuz you gotta find some
flow do you have like certain practices
like like you keep a journal with you
all that like oh I'm in the carpool lane
and you know Judy just said the craziest
thing to me and I write it down so yes I
do voice memos yeah on my phone which is
easier for me but no I used to write in
a journal here's a crazy thing I had a
journal that I was writing in for like
seven years and I cannot find it and I
have two teenage daughters yeah like
where's the journal who's reading the
journal cuz there is some [ __ ] in that
journal that should not be read by my
children because they don't have the
capacity to understand it I mean they
will some day if they could read when
they have children they more than
welcome to read it they'd laugh all day
long right right now they'd be so
sensitive so yeah I don't know where the
journalists it's blue royal blue leather
yeah pebbled journal if anyone has it
out there I'd really like you to send it
back because this is weighing on me just
a little bit yeah but now I don't have
any super-strong processes I mean the
thing I guess the only thing I would say
is I listen differently like I'm
listening really carefully and not only
am i listening to what stories you're
telling me but I'm also listening to
your response to me so if I'm in a room
with some women at a cocktail party or
having coffee or whatever and I say
something and then people start to crowd
around or there's like a big reaction I
definitely take note of that right like
I know it's resume I already know it's
resonating before I put it on the page
because I've touched it publicly in a
conversation so it's almost like a
stand-up comedian like working out there
yeah you know well it's but it's more
spontaneous than that it's like it's
just something to note it's not it's not
like I go in thinking oh I'm gonna try
that I'm gonna tell that story about
Mike
grandmother and see house who see how
they respond to it it's more like I
started telling story about you know so
like I'll come home and say dad word
like so interesting I was telling a
story about my grandmother and like
Allison liked the room got really quiet
and every was listen to me and I thought
oh my god I guess that's like a thing I
guess people would really want to think
about that yeah it's like that it's like
that yeah I think we did it all right
how do you feel good yeah hot I know I
know we have turned the AC off so it's
getting warm in here
thank you you're so welcome
yeah it's really fantastic
you absolutely delight me oh I am gonna
go back and read all your other books
yeah yeah we'll only take you like two
three hours I'm a pretty slow reader
okay thank you for having yeah of course
so if you're diggin on Kelly easiest way
to connect with you Kelly gorgon comm
Instagram Instagram I like it Graham
just Kelly cool and are you doing any
public events anywhere if people want to
come and connect with you no well tell
me more at bookstores everywhere yeah
all right cool thanks peace
[Music]